on Wednesday night I was in LA and I was
doing a friendship do you ever take a
drug and forget you take it and then
like an hour later
I
had forgotten I took the mushrooms and I
took two hits off this joint I'm like
this is the best bleed I've ever seen
smoker that weed was because I was like
you also ate some mushrooms I was like
oh yeah
and I was getting way higher than I
wanted to get right
so now for those of you who've ever
taken mushrooms before right right when
it's about to hit a lot of times you
gotta [ __ ]
it's not like a normal human
know I pray to those of you who have
taken them you know it's like uh yeah if
dude if an alien came down and saw it
they'd be like let's get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah I don't know what that is
these people are sick so no one takes a
[ __ ] on mushrooms like this damn I'll be
right back it's this hey I gotta I gotta
hey
so it's urgent right I'm sitting in the
green room and I say to my buddy who
booked me I go [ __ ] it I gotta go
without him so badly I mean
I'm on in five minutes he was like just
get go
so I go and I go to the bathroom it's a
literal [ __ ] show uh
I run out he goes you got a minute I go
[ __ ] great I go out I now guys to say
I'm high is not it's not it doesn't even
describe it right and so but I made 500
people [ __ ] show goes great I see a
ton of my friends right I get in an Uber
I go to another show it's 500 people I
see a ton of my friends I'm in three
more Ubers at night okay cut to Friday
I'm at the hotel
and I want to come to the show here and
I want to wear those pants
and there's
[ __ ]
straight across not on the inside on the
outside on the outside of my jeans above
my [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] no I did I
did two shows I saw almost every one of
my friends I was in four Ubers nobody
wanted to say you got [ __ ] on your pants
it was like and not this way like you
wipe like why is it horizontal
was like
[Music]
around like this all night on Wednesday
night
okay anyways
[Music]
that's how big her titties were they
made that noise through the air